[Musique]
de 51 sur 100 dans la catégorie bon
utilisé par plus de 37 millions de
personnes en Europe l'application Yuka
est disponible au Canada depuis 3 ans
sur 100 elle lit le code barre et en une
fraction de seconde révèle si un produit
est bon ou non pour la santé
de fibres de protéines Julie chapon a
cofondé Yuka en 2017
la philosophie derrière l'application
c'est vraiment d'avoir un impact positif
sur la société et donc d'aider les
consommateurs à faire des meilleures
fois pour leur santé et pour
l'environnement mais aussi de conduire
des industriels à améliorer leur offre
de produits Yuka reconnaît des dizaines
de milliers de produits au Canada c'est
une application collaborative c'est à
dire que les utilisateurs sont invités à
nourrir la base de données en ajoutant
des produits inconnus il y a tout un tas
de
contrôle qui sont ensuite réalisés il y
a beaucoup de technologie qui permet de
détecter automatiquement qu'une
information est incohérente ou erronée
l'application accorde ensuite une cote
au produit vert orange ou rouge et une
note sur 100 points le premier élan
c'est très enthousiasmant parce qu'on
est avec son téléphone on scanne puis
c'est vraiment super amusant puis on
voit les codes sortir
Yuka calcule cette note en prenant en
compte trois critères les valeurs
nutritives les additifs et si le produit
est biologique
[Musique]
moi je vous ai préparé quelque chose
aujourd'hui on va faire le test nous
avons demandé à la nutritionniste et
enseignante Nathalie Lacombe de tester
Yuka avec ses élèves alors l'équipe ici
vous allez travailler sur les céréales
et l'équipement vous allez travailler
sur le bord d'arachide vous allez
regarder le TVN la liste d'ingrédients
puis vous allez les classer soit du
meilleur au pire ou en catégorie
pour les valeurs nutritionnelles Yuka se
base sur la côte du nutri-score un logo
européen qui note la qualité nutritive
globale d'un aliment Yuka joue un rôle
assez important en France dans ce Serge
ergberg est le créateur du nutri-score
quels sont les points positifs pour vous
de cette application il y a eu
l'avantage de la fraction civilisée la
population sur ces problèmes les
industriels et également les politiques
donc il a joué un rôle non négligeable
dans la prise de conscience qu'il
fallait s'informer sur la qualité
nutritionnelle des aliments le
nutri-score est une très bonne la base
mais il nous semblait important de
compléter avec d'autres critères
Yuka accorde 30% de la note à la
présence d'additifs controversé ou non
donc quand un additif est très
controversé et bien effectivement on
l'indique en rouge
UK est un outil de prévention qui permet
de savoir que cette
problématique et donc d'éviter de
consommer des produits contenants
c'est-à-dire de manière régulière sur le
principe c'est très bien mais pourquoi
60 30 10 pourquoi pas 33 33 33 aucun
comité d'experts international il
organisation mondiale de la Santé n'a
conçu un tel outil parce que ça n'est
pas possible d'agréger cette différentes
dimensions donc Yuka se positionne mais
sans qu'il y ait derrière cela un vrai
support scientifique et il suffit d'un
additif controversé pour faire chuter la
note
plein de films plein de protéines s'il y
a un seul additif qui est considéré à
risque ça note maximum ça peut seulement
de 49 alors lui c'est cool parce qu'il y
a deux quantités en atelier le groupe
relève des contradictions
de 66 sur ça c'est un bon on nous parle
de la quantité de protéines qu'on ne dit
grave 11 g de fibres donc c'est sûr que
dans l'application ça a l'air très beau
même si ça prend pas en compte que le
premier ingrédient de cette céréale là
c'est un produit qui est transformé si
on tourne puis qu'on les classe
maintenant selon le score Yuka ça donne
quoi
alors on part d'un score de 84 72 66
60 57 et 49 alors que pour nous ces
trois-là devraient être en première
position moi
comment ça se fait de sucre des fruits
secs voilà les sucres libres ajoutés par
l'industrie ou le sucre présent
naturellement dans le fruit séché pas de
distinction là-dessus c'est comme ça
qu'on se retrouve avec un classement qui
est un cohérent autre exemple les beurre
d'arachide c'est mon épicerie je regarde
la liste des ingrédients ça dit arachide
arrachide arachide arachide
il y en a des excellents parmi ça puis
on peut toute la même cote ce qui est
drôle aussi c'est que ça dit que c'est
trop calorique mais là un moment donné
il faut bien manger
sur le terrain les résultats sont
parfois déconcertants
parce qu'en fait toutes les peintres
tranchées qui étaient disponibles ils
ont rarement des notes excellentes les
seuls qu'il y en avait c'était des pains
un peu plus artisanales qui ont pas
d'agents alimentaires ou d'agent de
conservation on l'a vu Yuka n'aime pas
les additifs il est donc possible qu'un
pain moins riche en graine entier mais
sans additif obtiennent une meilleure
note qu'un pain riche en fibres mais qui
contient des agents de conservation tout
est possible et encore une fois un
système de notation et forcément
réducteur un système de notaire prendre
en compte toutes les subtilités et la
complexité du vaste sujet qui est la
nutrition la mise en garde c'est
vraiment de se dire que Yuka est un
outil de prévention et pas un outil de
décision c'est un outil d'information
qui doit permettre aux consommateur de
faire des choix éclairés faut pas
arrêter de consommer les aliments qui
sont classés comme étant mauvais ou
médiocre juste parce que ils n'ont pas
des bonnes notes là souvent ces aliments
là ça veut ça peut nous apporter du
plaisir au final ce que ça fait c'est
que ça classe les aliments en deux
catégories les bons puis les mauvais
comme dans un vieux film western et ça
ça c'est dommageable
[Musique]